welcome back to on base live in your
Bleacher Report app I am here today
with the goat Mike Trout
what's going on bro how you doing yeah
I'm good man thank you for coming on
before we before we start I just want to
write off some uh some of your accolades
because these are pretty good
so three-time L MVP
10 time All-Star
nine times Silver Slugger
2012 Al rookie of the year so you know
how good that is
do you you know you gotta hold the mic
up though oh yeah ah yeah I mean
it's going by fast I'll tell you that
yeah it's uh blinking it's got 10
All-Stars yeah it's uh it goes by quick
um
It's a Grind obviously but I love it I
mean that's what you signed up for it's
this is
I love this stuff it's fun so so do you
remember when we first met bro
I don't remember I don't I don't but I
know since we have met yeah you know
you've been you know like a brother to
me bro like you know what I'm saying
when I see you I I'm happy to see you no
matter how good or bad I'm doing the
game
um you know we've been here for what
three years four years yeah now and I
hardly ever get to see you bro so you
know I think I think WBC definitely
helped that that definitely did happen
we'll get into that let me before we get
into that yeah before we get into that I
want to talk about uh we have this game
it's called on base off bases a few
things I want to ask you about for sure
on base you're in off space you're out
all right
so long form interviews interviews like
this are you in or out on them
anything over 30 minutes I'm out so
you're out on this perfect no no no no
no no no no it's all good would you move
but yeah it depends who's with yeah we
believe it yeah I mean if if somebody
you don't like no let's see but you
really out on them though so so you came
on for me yeah for sure my dog for sure
that's what I'm talking about it all
right so what about
um
being a fantasy football league
commissioner I don't know so obviously
for those who don't know there was an
altercation that happened yeah between
two players
I'm sure you can look it up for sure
it's out there read about it tell me
like from your perspective like the
things that you had to think about
because they had their two sides but
they didn't have your side I want to
hear yeah no I think you know going in
basically
you got rules before the seat before the
season starts and then they're the rules
and
a little miscommunication or whatever
went down someone was I'm not trying to
put anybody out there or anything but uh
you know stuff it was tough being
commissioned man I mean you got the
group chat every day something goes down
isn't on you yeah so but so do you have
to did you have to uh change any rules
because this no no no it wasn't fair or
you know whatever no I mean sure you
hear everybody's I ain't gonna call it
sob story but for the lack of better
term yeah no I mean both guys had a
legitimate argument right and you know
it was tough for me because
you know I'm not I mean there's a lot of
money on the line so it's like
this is what it was
um you know but it's a learning
experience for sure so you're not doing
it again no I'm definitely gonna be in
in the in the uh for sure in the league
but not I can miss we got uh Jay from uh
Jay runs and he's a commission okay so
now you feel better now yeah I feel
great I'm in a good spot on base or off
base Jalen hurts wins MVP next season
I'm on that you're on that oh yeah so
yeah I know you're a huge Eagles fan
that's your backyard like how was it
when uh going through the playoffs and
everything with the boys because I know
you're you're in it well yeah no I'm in
it um try to go to Every Game obviously
uh the way you know the biggest thing
for me is the way Jalen handled the
Super Bowl yeah you know after that uh
after that fumble
you know just the way it could tell
couldn't tell couldn't tell didn't phase
him didn't phase him at all and I mean
he's been through some some crazy stuff
he's got a great story you know it's um
you know one of the best stories out
there you know getting benched in the
national championship game and then uh
just going through all that and just
putting putting all the work all that
work in and
um you know I think looking at what he
did in the Super Bowl after you know the
fumble and then just being able to just
dominate you know just full composure
just um you know he's got it he's got it
sure you talked to him I talked to him
here and there and so is he he's just
that's him all the time or is that just
yeah I don't really know him personally
I don't know personally about here you
know talking to other players that
played with him yep and everything's
been great and positive so it's uh you
know he's one of one of my guys that I
like to watch for nice okay what about
uh calling a Taylor Ham a pork roll
calling a tit and I'm off that you're
off there so that for those who don't
know
from Jersey and they call I guess
these uh breakfast meats for a pork roll
can you can you explain a little bit of
that because my big Port Royal guy
um I never even heard that first saying
to be honest oh really yeah okay yeah
yeah so all right well yeah we'll be off
of it for sure okay so
um even though you don't really need to
be this kind of guy
um oh you're you you're kind of
self-proclaimed weather weatherman oh
yeah yeah even I mean La is beautiful
all the time for sure so boring but
boring when we go to the east coast you
love it I love it so you you know I
gotta you are in on storm chasing
stormzy so if there's a tornado you're
going forward well not obviously now
um during season and during the contract
years you know what I mean okay once I
once I've done baseball I've done
something when I'm retired I'm
definitely gonna go out to have uh you
know got to know a lot of storm chasers
and a lot of people that work for the
weather
um The Weather Channel you know
cantori's out there you know I talked to
re-timer every once in a while he chases
a lot um what is it about I I gotta know
yeah no I think like I just the second
one adrenaline rush I guess I don't know
you know I can't find other things to do
I'm sure I can I can go golf or
something but yeah I think I got brought
up you know my dad
always when the storm came you know we
watched The Weather Channel hey we got
some storms coming up and we always go
on the front porch watch them you know
just in the room and I mean I'm on the
porch so it's like yeah it wasn't you
would it wasn't the side rating no no I
mean you get away every once in a while
but as a kid you know you're playing in
the rain but I think my dad just you
know that snowstorms man I'm big on
snowstorms love snow love cold weather
love snow snow angel guy I mean
yeah I guess
so do you have a snowmobile at home no
no just it didn't rain it didn't it
don't snow that much in Jersey but
um you're just out there your son he
loves it oh he loves it yeah we go we
travel every every off season to try to
find
you know up and up in the Poconos or you
know we went to Aspen this off season
um we loved it so yeah okay so back to
what we were talking about earlier bro
the WBC
you know from my perspective getting to
play with you was was probably one of
the coolest things because it's really
we've only gotten to play All-Star game
together yeah and that's for 24 hours
and now we played what how many games
was it was it I think it was 10 10 games
or so yeah we have four and four uh
Arizona and then
eight ten games and dude it was so much
fun bro it was like getting to see you
strap it up every day getting to see
getting to talk the game with you
getting to just be around you it was
just it was just super super dope bro
and I wanna
tell you like thanks for uh just being
my boy dude yeah no that was that was
super cool and and super uh super neat
scene so I want to hear your perspective
on the WC like I kind of talked about it
like how much did you enjoy it bro loved
it loved every minute of it I think
like you said you know we play
we play with each other in All-Star game
one game you know a couple days we're
going I'm going this way you're going
that way
um to be able to get core
you know with that Elite Talent in one
room you know I still remember the the
the meeting we had in uh where were we
the Giants complex when the
d-ro was talking
um you know it gives me chills man just
thinking about it just coming together
and uh you know getting to know you
getting to know all the guys all the
guys yeah I mean we didn't have one guy
on that team that was just you know that
you would say like hey he needs to get
out no that was a team that was
literally a team it was full of stars
but it was a team yeah and getting like
getting to know everybody on a personal
level just it was it was cool you know
just we were hanging out at the pool
after the games yep you know all the
families were there
you know that was one of the coolest
experience I've ever had yeah it brought
back a lot of memories
um like travel ball days yeah I was just
like hey man we got a winner we're going
home yep so I remember I remember
um we were sitting at the locker one
game
right before the game
and we're putting our clothes on you
asked me like moot is is this what
playoffs feels like and that kind of
hit home like not hit home but like it
hit me and I was like Wow Mike Trout who
is
10-time All-Star nine times Silver
Slugger three-time MVP all these things
hasn't really experienced playoffs like
that and it's not a shot at you it's
just anything like people play this game
for 15 20 years and they never make
playoffs and then you get certain guys
that bounce around teams for six years
in a row and they're in playoffs every
year you know what I'm saying and so
um like that that to me that was beyond
playoffs
yeah north um obviously a little taste
in 14 but I mean
to get that taste pre-season yeah I mean
it was something different you know just
you know the fans
um
no the the championship game was the the
media coverage was I mean I've never
seen so many media I mean it was media
everywhere
um but just the the fans and how much
they cared about their country you know
I think that's that's what was different
about it it was just like something
something was different yeah you run out
in the field and you know they did you
know chanting USA and it's just it was
just different you know and um
you know it's just that's that you want
to be in big games like that yeah that's
why we play that's why we go play that's
why that's why we play we want moments
like that we wanna we wanna you know
remember that you know I mean
we always will we will and I think
that's what
that's why I told myself hey WBC in what
two three years I'm in I'm in we're all
we're all in when we get all the guys
too yeah don't worry we're gonna be
recruiting
so so okay so
it's the it's the I want to say the top
of the ninth
no top of eight
bottom eight because they were hitting
yeah
it was a bottom and an eighth and you
see showy warming up and it was 912 I
think right so when I saw him going down
there I was like oh boy here we go you
knew it was coming
and and
uh McNiel gets on I head into a double
play
so take me when you saw him in the
eighth inning Warren going down to
warming up what was your thought because
you know you had to face him this is
like this is like the perfect storybook
ending for sure for sure
um in the eighth inning what were you
thinking
what was I thinking I was like I'm gonna
get a chance to get him right here and
you know I
I don't think I've I honestly I haven't
I haven't faced him in live BP oh
nothing nothing so I haven't seen them I
just seen him from behind okay you know
I mean so I I know what he can do from
behind you that's just the the movements
I see it moving crazy yeah I missed some
pictures I should have hit yeah but I
mean yeah like that picture I should
have hit right there yeah but bro I
understand it's a hundred cutting I
understand like that you know what I'm
saying and so okay so you're on Deck I
head into a double play Boom now you're
walking to the plate what's going
through your mind bro what's going
through Mike Trout I gotta go deep here
gotta go deep here I think it might have
messed me up because it took me out of
my Approach but yeah yeah there was one
thing in my mind I was trying to take
him deep I mean there's no other there's
no other
there's no other explanation
you know I mean you know how it is I
know exactly what you're saying I I know
exactly and I think I think once I I
think I've gone deep like go up to the
plate and I'm like hey I gotta hit a
homer here I think I did it one time my
whole career that's what I'm saying and
I did it when I hit for the cycle oh
okay it was a 2-0 pitch I said this is
it if I'm gonna do it right here and I
hit a home but other than that it's not
it's I'm gonna get out see look at her
pictures though like when you went back
and looked at it oh you're nasty nasty
nasty and you knew he was gonna bring
his best stuff right there yeah and so
have you guys talked about it at all no
no I'm just gonna let it let it ride let
it ride I mean I'm
you know it's really not I mean you know
Shelley's show is a good dude man yeah
like great teammate you know just one of
them guys that wants to win man you know
we're both competitive you know you it's
uh
you know he's not
big cocky guy he's not you know that's
what yeah I was gonna rub in your face
what's it like playing with him every
day you know what I'm saying because
you're a superstar you know he's a
superstar yeah and you know really to be
real Mikey like he's he's he's by far
the biggest
like I've seen a lot of great players
I've played a lot of with a lot of great
players I've never seen
these last two weeks what he's done oh
my gosh the balls here is hitting in
Texas dude I don't even pull it up you
know what I'm saying I mean it's just
like
he's special man yeah I mean everybody
sees it so what is it what is it like
his routine and everything like that and
I'm not saying you have to break it down
but like is it like simple bro simple
this is super easy super easy
um just simple man it just comes in the
cage just hit hits a couple balls off
the tee
does some flips
goes out there and hits and that's it
that's it he doesn't do like a like a
machine I mean sometimes he hits uh the
red ball machine red ball machine yeah
like the little softballs that throw up
get some uh because all them guys are
throwing them fastballs up now because
of him but I think you know it's just
simple I think
you know he's just naturally gifted
naturally gifted I mean obviously you
know he puts the work in for sure it's
uh it's it's pretty impressive man so
and then and you guys are playing well
this year too you guys are you know
talking about playoffs you guys are I
think in in the place right now yeah I
know it's too early yeah but still it's
good and how it what's it what's it like
you guys got a lot of I'm not gonna say
young guys but different than when I was
there you know I'm saying I I haven't I
don't recognize a lot
some of these guys yeah for sure was it
is it through the draft like you know
how is it um the the clubhouse and
everything is unbelievable okay you know
Perry's gonna Perry's doing a great job
bringing guys up that uh you know just
great mindset great work ethic uh great
teammates that can play you know I think
you know we're going through a stretch
right now we're banged up a little bit
yep you know losing you know we have a
first loss so hoppy you know okay yeah
but um and then you know Neto a
shortstop oh yeah Tony just hit a couple
homers that is that is a superstar man
it's gonna be good yeah
um big leg kick guy big leg kick guy all
right it's uh it's it's special though
it's nasty everybody he he has that
little two-strike approach too yeah no
straws so it's uh it's pretty pretty
impressive to see it so far
um got some young guys coming up in the
bullpen Arizona
throwing hard throwing strikes we got
the veterans in the back end I mean it's
it's uh we got a good team and like you
said just got to ride that way man we're
playing good ball right now and just got
to keep it going so what do you feel
like you have to do to help help the
boys
you know just just keep keep them in
line man it's it's we got a deep deep
lineup you know we got we got guys that
are in there continue damaging it's just
not one one two guys that are you know
carrying us um
you know it's just you know go out there
and just you know pass the Baton yeah I
think that's you know it's it's it's
pretty pretty fun to play like that you
know it's you know I mean I mean in WBC
that's kind of that's what it was yeah I
think so I think maybe are you using
that experience
maybe not the whole experience but that
that thought yeah I think because you
see it well I mean you gotta you gotta
look at this way man the atmosphere you
want that yeah I texted Nev right after
the game I said hey I need this this is
it right here I need this experience man
this was fun yeah you know the emotions
came out and I think I don't know who
whoa I don't know who said it but we had
a meeting before the game we were like
hey man we got to match their energy it
may have been me yeah probably that
sounds like we gotta Master energy like
they're hitting home runs base hits
they're going crazy on the field you
know we're hitting home runs base hit so
we're just you know just clapping stuff
like let's get let's get going so are
you using that with the guys now yeah I
think just having fun man just that's
how it should be you know it's just
that's what it was show the emotion man
just you know obviously there's there's
a there's a line for it yeah for sure
you don't show up the other team too
much but you know you get a big knock
late in the game you know the Energy's
flowing it's you need that and I think
the fans want that you want and think
every I think everybody you know that
wants that okay so tell me about like a
routine for you like when you when you
get to the field like a little game day
routine game day routine so I get there
probably like noon okay that's an early
launch it is it is
um you know I launched
then I go to the the table and the
training table yep get stretched out for
a little bit you know it's different you
know it's different now you know I'll be
32 in August it ain't like just show up
to the field I wasn't sure if I showed
up to the field and didn't do anything I
probably wouldn't do anything
I got to go through a whole routine yeah
okay so for you so go ahead go to the
field get like probably like 45 minutes
of treatment just like loosen up you
know whatever it is it's kind of same
routine every day
um
and then pickles I love pickles you eat
pickles before the game still I remember
you said no no no you don't do it
anymore no no I used to have a kid yeah
okay maybe I should start now but uh no
um it's one o'clock roughly yeah one
o'clock roughly I you know chill for a
little bit and then I'll get loose in
the cage
um and then at home it's different from
home and away because you know home you
got the uh we got field at 2 30. so I
like hitting breaking balls okay I like
hitting on the field I usually hit them
in the cage but now this year we were
starting to do it on the field okay just
to see the um trajectory trajectory of
the ball and stuff
and then
I'll stretch maybe do a little defensive
work go in get a little bite to eat
take like a 45 minute nap oh nap guys
just started I started this you know I
think you enjoy that I enjoyed that it's
not it's not like a some days I nap some
days I just go in there and chill yeah
you know it's more about the just the
rest just the rest and then uh
you know we gotta uh the hitters meeting
you know go over to go over the starter
that night before
or that night and then uh
getting the tubs for contrast and then
shower up then get in the cage again
so you don't have like a detailed
specific time like at at 2 53 I do this
no no no so you just kind of that's what
Kershaw was saying that right yeah that
was I saw that um no and I think
it varies okay I mean it's not like but
you have a roughly it's 250 something I
need to probably be heading that yeah
exactly yeah for sure so you try and get
there early so you don't have to rush
through it yeah take your time I don't
like Russian so okay and if you do Rush
are you like out of whack
I feel yeah so I think that's one of my
like Pet Peeves in the cage okay being
rushed you know
you're trying to get you're trying to
work on things and then
you know you gotta you got limited time
or there's people behind you like they
need to get in the cage so it's like
I'm a big guy that like I need to feel
right when I leave that cage so
um so do you think like uh things like
that little details like not being
rushed into cage because you've been one
of the best players in the game for I
don't even know how many years
and like do you feel like little details
like that is what's huge at the top I
think it's huge little stuff like that
um it's not just it's what goes into you
got it preparing yeah I think
preparation I mean
sometimes you go to the end of the game
when you don't feel good you get you
have some success success but
when I'm when I feel good walking out of
that cage when I walk to the box I feel
like I can't get out you know so you you
would say what's kept you at the top is
just the way you prepare
yeah I think like
yeah
but it's not even it may not necessarily
be just baseball it could be like your
body yeah and you're preparing your body
for the season preparing yeah you're
mine for the season you know what I'm
saying yeah I think you know having a
couple setbacks I think has helped me
because I learned from it yep you know I
now I know I'm doing a lot more stuff
that I used to that I haven't done
before you know like you said when I was
when I first came up it was like come to
the field hit BP play the game yeah you
know I know like work on your legs you
know it's now it's like I'm in a routine
where you know I feel good when I go on
that field you know if it's the best I
felt in a while you know this close to
the break that's good okay so so before
let's go back to early Mike Trout right
you play short shorts I'm growing up
how's that how did you did you love
playing Source over you I loved it you
know obviously uh I was a big Jeter fan
okay so I play short side my whole life
short stop and pitched
are running through my early days yeah
yeah yeah yeah let me hear about a
couple so I was short stop and pitched
all the way to about my my junior year
in high school okay
and uh I would throw like six five six
Innings and then go to shortstop oh you
finished the okay all right you know
like when I came out again I just go to
shortstop okay so
um
then then the scouts were like hey man
this kid's gonna his arm's gonna be gone
so it's kind of like so it's kind of
like
a pitch and then just go to center field
man you fast you can catch a fly ball
like go to Centerfield yeah you don't
have to throw that much you're not you
know less wear and tear on the body and
uh that's how I got moved to center
field I feel okay so it was just because
it was because I pitched okay yeah
speaking of pitching yeah you had an 18
Punchy guy I did tell me about that yeah
in warm-ups did you know you're about to
punch out a bunch of guys or like was it
just it just how it just happened
um
you know I think everything was working
that day my arm felt really good
um I think I still had a little fastball
or curveball even mixing a knuckleball
every once in a while he threw a
knuckleball just to mess around and you
had a no-hitter right yeah no hitter and
did you throw knuckleballs in though I
don't know if I threw one I just do it
so you were really up there just I was
having fun bro I told you not guys
throwing his heart what were they doing
were they not trying to hit I was
located son oh my God
we were talking about this we were
talking about this the other day because
uh because Crawford came into pitch okay
like 85 yeah yeah and he was like uh
and I was talking to devil in the bench
about this I was like Hey by the end of
my career I won't get an ending yeah are
you gonna are you gonna let it eat it
depends okay depends who it is okay I
might I might flip the first one over
and then if I get the two strikes you
never know what's gonna happen so you
know I mean you gotta go yeah you gotta
do it okay so okay so you get drafted
going through the miners how was the
minor leagues did you enjoy them
um I did
um do you have any of my good good bus
stories that the bus broke down I mean
yeah the bus broke down a couple times I
think you know a lot of people don't
know like never heard this but
um so like I'm 17. okay get drafted boom
really close to my family
like real close to my parents
and I mean they did everything for me
like it was like
it was like yeah go to Arizona and you
know you're on your own cooking yeah
laundry everything cleaning you know
it's like wow it's like wake up and like
two probably about a month in bro I was
homesick bro to a point where I was like
well I don't know if I'm this ain't for
me yeah you know I mean and then so
who'd you call them like who did you
talk to that kind of because I remember
I remember I had the same combo and I
called my boys yeah I talked to a lot of
people my wife at the time and and and
like it was I remember crying yeah no I
think you know having Jess my wife
um
through the experience and my parents as
well and just I think being able to come
out every once in a while just to I
don't know if it was a good thing or a
bad thing because like it was cool when
they came out but when they left it was
like back to square one yeah so you know
that was tough for me and then you know
I was just fighting through it you know
uh Randall grichuk was my roommate okay
okay
um you know we were we were drafted back
to back and you know we kind of
you know we're like hey let's you know
they put us in uh the Homestead Suites I
mean it was like I don't even know if
it's there anymore but uh you know it
was that was tough for me yeah you know
getting through the uh being homesick
you know that was that was a grind once
you got over that edge though once I got
over that edge it was you know I enjoyed
it okay you know I think
um you know you had one goal in your
mind just keep moving up you're moving
up so I got went to rookie ball
then I got uh caught up to the playoffs
and in low a after that season
um then went to instructional League
instructor oh yeah it was instructions I
mean when you get invited to instructs
what's your first thing you're like man
it's off season It's a Grind it's good
though it was good though I went to it
it was good you know I think but it's
just an extra at the time an extra month
yeah of more baseball it was but I mean
you know I mean
you know they they draft you you got one
thing in mind to get to the big leagues
nope and uh you know went from there and
then I went uh the next year I broke
with Cedar Rapids
and halfway through the year
um went to got caught up to
Inland or not inland
uh Rancho Rancho you guys are Rancho
yeah yeah so we were Rancho
and then finish the year there did you
struggle at all or did you just kind of
bang your um
yeah I mean I went through some skits
for sure but you know I was one of them
it's just one of the things where it's
just like
you know get it get out of that skid as
fast you can you know normal stuff so so
at what point in the minor leagues or
even it could have been in the big
leagues like did you know that you were
this good
um I think when I got sent back down
when I came up
so I got the call I was
I was in double A I was in my apartment
it was late at night I gotta I heard my
phone ring okay I'm sitting there
and it's at Orange County
and I I was like this is like midnight
and I didn't answer it like I didn't
know who it was
and then I got a voicemail and then they
called again I answered okay for sure
today you're going to the big leagues
and then once I got caught up
you know I struggle they're like two 205
or something you hit some homers
whatever but uh and I got sent back down
and it kind of was like wow
it's kind of like a wake-up call like
hey man like
let's go like and I got the next year I
think so what when you had that wake-up
call though what was it that you did
because just the wake-up call is not
enough like yeah like it calmed me down
okay like call me now because I I went
up there I was trying to do way too much
okay you know you go in this game you go
up there trying to hit homers every time
you're gonna get out you're gonna get
out especially nowadays with a guy's
gone yeah 100 yep so
um I think
um being able to just calm myself down
when I got called back up the next so
how did you calm yourself down just like
being in the moment like taking a deep
breath like just trying to I see you do
that now though like when you get in you
kind of yeah I try to calm myself down I
think when you're up there tents and
trying to hit the ball so hard and you
know for me personally I mean it might
work for other guys to go up there and
try to launch right I mean I'm trying to
hit the ball hard for sure I'm trying to
get my a swing off but I'm not trying to
hit the ball to the 55 freeway every
time you know I think
um it might work for others but not for
me so I think being able to like
you know get fail that one time fail
that you know month and a half I was up
there
um to be able to come back you know just
be
I knew what to expect to calm myself
down
um
you know just just to be myself yeah you
know what got me there okay you know
this when I when I came up and I did was
like trying to hit like I said hit the
ball far that's not me right you know
just homers yeah you know have to take
my swing and you know things happen so
so so
do you have like a hitting coach or
somebody that you work with outside of
the Angels
or or that you're using the minor
leagues that kind of helped you become
that have the swing that you have now or
is it just kind of like natural bro you
know it's if you look it's funny because
I see some like every time the draft
comes up you see I see myself yeah I see
my old swing and it's uh it's kind of
the same swing you know I've had some
great great uh hitting coaches over the
years you know uh Jeremy Reed you know
Paul Sorrento
um
they were the guys that been with angels
for a long time so I got a relationship
with them and uh you know it's we've had
some
um some some crazy times in the caves
man like there's been some times in
August I'm
I'm out in a cage and you know it's like
man where did my swing go you know oh
yeah you've been there oh my God that's
a grind says you know it's easy it's
either you go in there and you take like
three or five like five to ten swings
like man my swing feels good I'm out
yeah and then there's times when you're
in there grinding bro sure all sweating
whole basket hey man you gotta calm down
like you're hitting too many boss
um but uh you know we got Phil and and
Marcus this year they're they're great
man that's that's you know they get it
you know they want you to they want to
they want you to be the best out there
and you know it's just um I was
my swing's been the same though yeah
it's easy so it's just natural for you
yeah I mean it's really I mean you look
over the years I'm sometimes I'm more
open sometimes I'm more close yeah but
that's just little field yeah a little
just little feels so so but
I want you to answer this bro
when did you know like
I'm Mike Trout like I'm I'm this good
like or do you not do you just don't
want to say it because I'll say it I
mean I'll say it for you but I I really
feel like like for you to stay where you
are you have to know who you are you
know what I'm saying and so
yeah I mean there wasn't one particular
moment okay where I'm like
I figured it would have been like after
the second MVP or something like okay I
think after that after my rookie year I
I like sit back I was like wow man this
is this is crazy man but um you know
for me it's just like
it's just it's just a baseball game you
know I kind of you even think about it
from that I'm not like that that cocky
guy that's gonna no you don't have to be
you don't have to be cocky to just be
like you know what like because in order
for me to be mookie like I'm not I'm not
saying I'm you bro like you know what
I'm saying like you have all these
accolades this any other but I feel like
in order for me to be good I had to be
confident yeah oh you got to be
confident you know what I'm saying I
have to be like okay at the end of the
day you're mookie bro guys blessed you
with these abilities you have them go
you it's so hard it's just hard
sometimes when you're going through it
when you're going yeah yeah for sure
like and I and I I still tell myself
this today
um you know like you said that you look
in the mirror say yo I'm still Mookie
Betts you know yeah I'm the real deal
you know what I mean and and I still
tell myself this when I walk on that
field when I go up you know before the
game look in the mirror and like I'm the
best player on this field you got to
have the confidence You Ain't Got
Confidence you ain't
it's sometimes it's hard because you're
grinding you know sometimes that that uh
when you're when you're at the plate
they're flipping up Tic Tacs you know
you ain't seeing nothing so
yeah we all been there man it's uh but
it's still I mean you gotta you gotta
have the confidence it's all about
confidence yeah you got to walk in a box
like hey for me if I Got Confidence I go
up there and I get out at least
you know I'm not going up there saying
man I can't I ain't gonna get a hit yeah
I mean at least at least you got
yourself a chance a chance exactly
exactly so let's switch gears for a
second because I know you're a big golf
guy yeah big golf guy so
tell me about this project you got going
on I know we talked about uh talked
about a little bit in spring or during
the WBC and you were super excited about
it like you were telling me about it and
I'm like this dude is really
like he loves golf so tell me about it
tell me about tell me what about your
new project yeah so
um you know I started playing golf right
around like 16. okay I wish I would have
started a little younger but I probably
did but it wasn't like I didn't really
get into it
and then um
you know I think everybody around the
game of baseball likes golf yep for the
most part um you know a lot a lot of
retired guys that play or even during
the season you know play
um and my wife
um she really does like she likes
wedding planning and stuff so
um
you know I think one of my you know like
dream would be like hey
that's you know on the course okay and
I've obviously been blessed and you know
fortunate enough to you know to
to do this and
you know an opportunity came up
it came to you
it so it started with I was going to
purchase a golf course okay and then you
know covert hit is that the first did
you like when you sign your deal were
you like I'm gonna buy a golf course
with this no it wasn't okay it wasn't
but a golf course came up for sale okay
and uh you know we kind of went through
it and like doing talking to all my
people and um
you know I was like man this is crazy
like this is it's about to be real and
then covert hit and it kind of stuff
fell through with the course and then
um
I was in I wasn't actually in a hot tub
before a game
and I was on the phone and someone sent
me a video
the video it was a video of a Drone
footage of a guy putting in a driving
range behind this building he's uh John
he owns uh Precast and uh I sent it to
my brother I said hey man you know look
into this see what see what he's going
on see what he's got going on over there
and uh we built a relationship and he
was he was one of them he was a guy that
you know when covet hit all the golf
courses got closed down and he was like
well if I can't go off I'm gonna build
it and build like a little range maybe a
little three-hole course and have all
his employees and stuff
um
you know come play golf it's like all
right and then you know things just
start escalating a little bit and then
we it turned into an 18 whole luxury
course man so he did you say
make it 18 holes over was it his idea or
how you know what was your involvement
in it yeah no
um you know obviously 18 holes
um with a nine hole you know a little
par three to make it 20 you know
um yeah
um and you know it's
playing golf over the years it was
pretty cool because like I played a lot
of great golf courses and I get to
figure out like hey I like this I don't
like that
I love
I love being on the golf course not
seeing houses okay you know I think okay
yeah so you know I think just putting
little things like that into into a
course and making it like your own okay
you know so you were pulling in on that
I mean yeah I honestly I wish I
you know I obviously during the season
you know offseason I'm involved like a
lot a lot of meetings every day
um you know during during the season is
tough you know because but even during
the season I mean you still are involved
to to oh yeah for sure for sure for sure
you know making the decisions and stuff
and just being on on the calls and stuff
but you know I think being able to you
know build your course and obviously you
know having tiger design it oh yeah so
have you developed a relationship with
him yes so you know um it's it's pretty
it's pretty special man just to be able
to talk to them you know just watch them
grow because he's the reason I've
started Golf okay just watch a tiger I
was a big tiger guy I mean I guess
everybody everybody you know it's just
you know you think you think your golf
is Tiger you know I think
um and to be able to have like a you
know a great relationship with them and
let them work of course it's pretty cool
to just be able to sit back and say Hey
you know this is how this is how I like
it you know and have y'all walked it
together not yet we are yeah it's coming
up
but I'm really looking forward to that
and
um you know like just
you know texting them on the side just
yeah even even like I think he's a
baseball fan oh big baseball fan he
knows his stuff he knows his stuff so
and yeah we play play Firestone
um about a month ago and I texted him
hey what's your tips you know he's won
there like eight times it took like 40
million yeah so he's he's uh he's been
there and he's just you know just
driving straight make putts yeah that's
just the name of golf so what would be
um what would be what's your favorite
course you've played so far favorite
course I've ever played it's a tough one
um that's okay no no I mean I play some
Great Courses um Silver Leaf oh
AZ you know Jay Ops course I think
that's that'll be up there yeah
um I really like Firestone man you
haven't played Augusta haven't played
Augusta got invited
a couple times but I'm sure down there I
want to play that I want to play it bad
so we got Somebody's gotta be out again
yeah can somebody get a song give me
exactly on Augusta please come on please
uh you do have a hole in one I do where
was it at it was at the Raven in Arizona
um how oh how far was it it's like one I
think it was like 137 or something a
little flip wedge little wedge yeah one
hop dunk what'd you do win nuts I went
nuts it was me you run straight to the
hole it was me my brother-in-law Aaron
he passed away uh uh and my wife Jessica
um and there was one more person but we
were actually talking about the other
day because I went golfing with Jess
um okay
yeah we just no it was one of them ones
where I just I tackled all of them yeah
I I didn't know what to do did you have
to buy everybody drinks no no I mean
when I walked back to the to the to the
clubhouse people were you know like hey
man you got the bar tab like messing
around yeah Raven actually literally it
was a late round so we were kind of like
the last ones ago and um
they they took the hole out and gave me
the whole flag everything oh wow that's
the word of that now is that a house
and then it's funny too because my wife
gives me messes with me all the time
because that same round
she was 176 out for on a par uh Par Four
and she buried it
she played she played a lot before we
had before we had Beckham okay yeah yeah
so let me add what's your dream foursome
bro a dream for some you and three other
people me and three other people I would
say me me obviously
go tiger okay MJ and Brady
Brady yeah
I love Brady man what so what what makes
what how does I'm obviously we know
Brady's to go right but like how does he
sneak in there like what what is it
about him that you love so much I mean
who don't like Brady I mean there's a
lot there's a lot of there's a lot of
people that don't like him right yeah
yeah for sure Dolphins fans and you know
all them guys but uh
just the way he the way he is on the
field man as a a another athlete
watching greatness I mean it's it's
something it's awesome I I being in
Boston and seeing him
I was always the only one that that
cheered for him because everybody hates
Brady yeah and in Boston well I'm about
well not in Boston but like when we left
and yeah super bomber in the Super Bowl
uh when they came back against Atlanta I
was the only one cheering chair yeah and
I was quiet the whole first half that we
was getting knew it was coming back yeah
but you would think you would think
right and so when uh a touchdown here
and a touchdown there boy I got loud
Brady Brady doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense so so and and you
know what who'd you say who'd you say MJ
MJ tiger and Brady
and you I'm gonna jump in there yeah so
we need to make that happen at Augusta
yeah
Mikey MJ tiger and Brady Brady we're
gonna make that happen all right so so
in your big top the top golf guy you
like Topgolf I mean
yeah I mean you go yeah I go yeah yeah
for sure so I got some swings here I
want you to uh to look at
I want to see yours first let's see
yours first because this I think you had
to see that yeah I I had this I knew
this one we need to uh can we pull up
the area here we go right here
you knew you got that one too yeah look
at you yeah yeah so that was that was
actually I think uh Justin Turner's oh
okay okay uh Topgolf event yeah during
uh spring and man we were up there
and I don't know who I think was Cody
Bellinger Cole Calhoun we were up there
just trying to launch and uh yeah I mean
I just I don't swing like that on the
course no of course I just try to hit it
as far as I could okay let's pull up the
next one can we pull the next one patma
homes and Pat's playing in my home yeah
he's playing in the uh the match so I
want you to look at this this swing
right here and tell me if you think it's
gonna win or not
that's what he's doing if he's doing
that he's gonna lose
that ain't his Gosling bro he's doing it
I don't think it is either I'm gonna go
with that ball is moving dude
it's coming out yeah his boy's hitting
it out it's coming out okay yeah now
that's hard to do I didn't know that was
happening okay Alex Morgan let's see
here look at her golf swing
it's not terrible that's not that's not
that's not bad
that's not too bad okay listen the next
one the next one she I I I would assume
that she has it with a good golf swing
uh this
because she's one of the best apps
you got a rotation just
yeah that's what she does though she's
used to it look at that hold on hold on
run it pause that back is your hands
right
I think I've seen that can we run that
back one more time she's doing it like
that that's that's I've seen uh somebody
chips like that on the tour
I was just watching those reverse hand
okay look at this one look at this one
out of all people in the world
that's what we got look at this one it
makes sense though
it is LeBron I saw it
we finally found something that LeBron
may not be that great at
I don't know I mean I don't think that's
a bad golf swing
I love him to death but that's a bag off
swing
Okay so
uh we got some questions of some fan
questions okay the first one would Mike
be interested in starting the next happy
in starring in the next Happy Gilmore
movie 100 you would love that oh I love
that one of my favorite movies ever
Happy Gilmore and you you would big Adam
Sandler fan yes
huge I see Adam Sandler walking around
sometimes it's great I love it and and
he's just a normal dude and I love it
love how it goes to like a pickup
basketball game just Dominate and just
dominates Doug all right Maggie shorts
Maggie Nothing fits nothing let's love
it okay so are you pulling out all the
stops to convince Otani to stay during
free agency 100 yeah who wouldn't want
that they're gone I feel like you have
to like I mean what
let's just throw out a random number how
much do you think he he'll get in free
agency I think he's anywhere between
five and six
just so you know how many M's that is
there's a lot of M's oh my gosh I mean
let's let's I mean I asked a lot of
people this how many years do you think
he has of doing both
that's the part that I don't know
because I really how old is he
2019 I think I think but that's that's a
serious question like people ask me all
the time like I see them every day yeah
I've never seen them so like yeah what
would you I mean I would say of doing
both
six yeah five or six yeah that's tough I
mean you know we play every day like we
know how to especially it's his his
level you know what I'm saying like he's
not he's not just out there
just getting some hits and and clogging
up bases like he's fat he's still in
bases you know he's
getting off the mound starting and then
he's leading off the inning you know
what I'm saying and still in the base
and then you know so he he I gotta give
it to him bro he works man yeah I mean I
mean yeah I mean that's why I think any
between five or six that's so much money
that's a lot of money okay so
um
you look jacked how much do you bench I
don't really bench that much
I'm a big bench guy I've seen that in
the WBC
I'm I'm little bro I'm little so I gotta
I gotta get strong some way and I I
treat myself like an athlete and not a
baseball player and so I train more like
a like a more like a football player
because my trainer is a play played in
the NFL but I think I think for me it's
just like maintaining it yeah you know I
work hard in off season yeah I work hard
in all season and then you know I'm not
going in there and Max pension every day
no you know I might throw up you know
70s or 80s just to get it you know keep
it going but I I have to though yeah I
do because if I don't I'm gonna get I'm
already little you know what I'm saying
so I did see you throw up some uh
all right so who who do you think is the
you of the NFL
um I mean obviously in the past it was
they they call me Brian Urlacher because
I look like Brock
you know me but
nowadays you think there's one now
I don't know man I don't think so um
not on the top of my head
okay so next question who's the toughest
pitcher to face toughest picture to face
that's a tough question and I I
I could answer that question because I
truly feel like
since we came up
glad you're bringing this up since we
came up I remember when we played in the
minor leagues like we were facing guys
that were throwing 90 93 you know get
your heads just any other then you get
to the big leagues you know now was
92 to 95 a little bit some guys and you
have that guy in the blue pen that maybe
you throw 97. yeah one or two guys and
now now
I mean since four or five years ago
hitting is it's completely different it
is it is hard to keep up with
it is
um like you said you know you you turn
on the College World Series now
everybody's throwing a hundred uh in the
College World Series guys you throw 85.
I know it's it's crazy and I think like
you said the guys when when I first came
up out of high school even high school
you go to high school now all the kids
are throwing 95 Plus
and I think guys that you know people
the kids that are coming up now are
they're used to all this yeah you know
and then we got guys you know it's you
see
you know the bullpens now even the
starters man like everybody bro we faced
the Marlins a couple uh about three
weeks ago and everyone I didn't see one
pitch under 97. and that's crazy you
know the starter at how hard it is to
hit when nothing's under 97 yeah it's uh
you got to be right you got to be right
so so
in that the evolution of you know when
we first started to now
how have you what have you done to help
yourself maintain this because is it
more like machine work or is it like you
have to think about different things in
your swing do you have to work on
different things what what is it that
because for me I do for me like for me I
had to hit even though I don't like to
hit the machine because it messes up my
timing it messes oh yeah yeah me too but
I have to see it yeah because if you
don't see it you're going up there it's
going to look a million yeah you know
what I'm saying and so like what do you
have to do yeah no I think uh like you
said I don't
before this year I don't think I've ever
hit the fastball machine okay and then
obviously now you know this year you
know they're throwing a lot of fastballs
and I've been struggling but
if I'm in a good spot to hit I'm I'm for
me my confidence and my swing I feel
like I hit anything it's just I've been
a bad spot so
um
it's seeing like you said you got to see
the see The Velo before you go out there
yeah if not it's gonna look look hard
hard but uh
but the biggest thing is
with the machine is I gotta
I got a sequence you know I got okay
like a rhythm yeah you know it's like a
I got a leg kick yeah it's like you got
no arm no arm slot and it's just like
yeah and I mean if you you go in there
not in a good spot but you're gonna walk
out there with no hands yeah it's gonna
get worse and so that's I think
a big thing for me I go and then I start
battling with the with the machine and
it's like no no we're not supposed to
battle with the machine you don't get
hit yes so I go in there but I mean you
know that's part of kind of uh what we
have to do because I mean like you said
man this new this next generation of of
guys and and we're still gonna be
playing yeah this next generation of
guys just everybody's gonna be throwing
100 miles an hour I'm gonna be hiring
that yeah and I'm curious to see how the
game is is gonna go because man how much
more can it change do you like the real
changes by the way the the new the you
know the the pitch timer I love the I
love it
um you know I think
something like it should be tweaked a
little bit I think
no one on base you take a full hack yeah
and you got you look up you got 13
seconds
at eight at eight again it turns quick
um
you know I think they should add a
little bit like that but I like the pace
of the game yeah I love it you know it's
it's
I mean who who likes four-hour games
nobody nobody nobody and now I mean now
I play the other day I played like a
three and a half hour game and it was
like 12 Innings yeah you know what I'm
saying that used to be
no I think it's I think it's good it's
better for the game better for you know
the athletes better for the players
um you know it was definitely adjustment
yeah
um
you know some pitchers use it for an
advantage you know I think yeah for sure
for sure it's uh you know we were on uh
we played the Royals the other day and
it got rengifo with this cranky did he
caught time out right away and then
you know when gifos in the box and
Greinke's off the mound and it was eight
seconds oh and you know I was like yeah
as a hitter he's not ready I'm not ready
yeah he's not ready and having to me it
happened to me too I didn't get a
violation but
uh I was in the box
there was like four seconds left on the
clock and the Pitcher stepped off the
rubber
and then I stepped out of the box
and then the Umpire called a Timeout on
me and I'm like oh the do-step like yeah
so it was kind of like a little mix up
but you know you're living and learning
but I I enjoy it I think like I said
it's good for the game yeah yeah okay I
got another question you got your own uh
you got your shoe
but who do you think is worthy of of
another
signature shoe
um
you know that's a good question I think
you got to go showy I I was gonna I mean
I think the easiest question I think
he's got a shoe coming out I think he's
with New Balance yeah yeah
so okay and then uh one more question
you watch the match I'm assuming we got
Pat Travis Kelsey
and Steph and Clay who who you got
winning that I think Pat Travis Scott
Steph clay I mean
I haven't really seen Pat workout or uh
yeah Kelsey play
um I've seen Curry play and he's I don't
think he's careful he's caring he's got
to and I saw I saw the other day I saw
uh Clay Thompson working out of the
bunker
it looked all right yeah so I I gotta go
Curry I think I got to go curry with
that yeah I gotta go Kurt so bro you got
any questions for me man I mean we can
just chop it up or you got any questions
for me
no you know I think uh
you know it's like I said over the years
you know playing against you man I
respect your game
thank you bro love love it love how you
go out there and play every day I think
the fans appreciate it and that's what
like you know another outfielder man
it's just like the Friendship we built
over the years yeah it's it's sick you
know and and got getting to know you
more yeah I think that's the biggest
thing biggest thing yep yeah we play
against each other we see each other in
All-Star games or whatever and you know
you don't really get to
the the deeper conversations and now you
know realizing you know what we were
talking about last night it's like hey
you know sometimes you sometimes you
when you're at the dish you're like you
feel like you're on top of the world and
then the next game is like there it goes
you know there's so much highs of those
in this game and the way you handle it
you know it's it's special you gotta
that's that's why you know you're the
person you are today thank you thank you
bro I say the same thing about you man
you know being on the other side and
like I said earlier it's just it's just
super dope and for a while you know for
a while you were the guy you you well
you are the guy and like you actually
helped drive me and you you would never
know this but like I was like you know
what I want to be like him like I want
to be as good as him
and so you were actually driving me to
be better and be better and be better
and then now you know I feel like I've
become
whoever I am and it's a lot of it is
just because of I was just trying to
keep up with you bro yeah and then now
now as it's like I'm maybe because I was
younger yeah and now I'm like you know I
I appreciate just good ball plays yeah I
appreciate good people and good ball
players that play the game the right way
and obviously you're one of them bro and
so thank you for coming on the show man
hope you enjoyed it no it's been a
pleasure anytime hey before we wrap that
ground ball yesterday for those who
didn't see our game yesterday the ground
ball they hit the rock it hit the rock
and bounced over hey buddy story because
I told the inning before I told our uh
our ground had ground screw Barney he
was going out there to put the uh
put the third base because it was like
still third or whatever I told I
literally told him I said hey man the
field isn't
a great shape and then that happens
so I gotta talk about his name Marty
Barney Barney yeah all right Barney
hopefully you're watching man and uh you
know he uh the the field is in great
shape yeah no that's great that's one of
the crazier cops and it's crazy it was
just part of the game part of the game
man sometimes they go your way sometimes
they don't for sure anyways thank you
guys for coming to watch uh my boy Mike
Trout came to stop by uh thank you for
coming bro we will see you guys next
time
foreign